[Music]
the one thing you miss most about your
brother I don't miss anything to me he's
still with me
[Music]
only et was invited inside princes
private compound Easley Park which has
now become a museum for fans to
experience up close and personal but
setting up the museum require the
cooperation of prince's sister tyka
nelson and several half-siblings
there have been rumours of squabbling
over the rights to Prince's estate where
do things stand right now with the trust
and your siblings will we know who are
the heirs besides you um I think we're
now finally on the last leg we're
finally through the hundred and ninety
five thousand people that said they're
related Sycho says she and her half
siblings meet peacefully every week
nobody's throwing nothing people are
eating and we sit around you walk in Mia
hi sister hi sister I think people want
to think we're fighting yes and so I
make jokes about it and I'm like oh you
know I'll walk in the room and go okay
what are we fighting about today walking
around in here it feels like your
brother yeah he's still here he's still
here and that's what's so wonderful
about it is that it's authentically him
that's unbelievable
you
[Music]